Vanilla Clans die sorgen seit Jahren für
Gewalt Verbrechen und Fassungslosigkeit
in der Hauptstadt die Behörden die
scheinen das Problem einfach nicht in
den Griff zu bekommen ja von der
eventuellen neu stattfinden in Berlin
weil da fordert der Berliner CDU-Chef
Kai Wegner jetzt einen deutlich härteren
Umgang mit den Kriminellen Großfamilien
und Bild liegt dieses Schreiben exklusiv
vor
Großeinsatz in Berlin mega Razzia gegen
kriminelle Großfamilie Ende August
dieses Jahres stürmt diese Einsatz
Hundertschaft den remo-familiensitz in
Berlin doch bilder wie diese beinahe
eine Seltenheit in der Hauptstadt Abu
Chaka Arsene Remo diese Familien
dominieren den Untergrund
[Musik]
die Bekämpfung braucht viel Personal und
einen langen Atem die Politik gibt uns
beides nicht
so äußert sich Bodo Pfalzgraf Berliner
Chef der Deutschen Polizeigewerkschaft
gegenüber Bild
für Schlagzeilen und Empörung sorgen die
kriminellen Clans durch ihre Straftaten
wie den 100 Kilo Goldmünzen Raub den
Einbruch ins Luxuskaufhaus KaDeWe oder
ihre öffentlich ausgetragenen
Familienleben
das sind natürlich schon sehr sehr
nachdrückliche Straftaten die auch
Eindruck machen sollen übrigens in der
Community und dadurch steigt sozusagen
das Ansehen der Respekt und der macht
einen Fluss und das eben genau das
gefährliche wo ich sage da muss der
Staat definitiv intervenieren doch
inzwischen weiten die kriminellen Clans
ihren Einfluss aus
Autovermietung Sicherheitsgewerbe
Shisha-Bars vermeintlich legale
Geschäfte vermeintlich
ihre Angst zur Rechenschaft gezogen zu
werden gering die Bundeshauptstadt ist
auf dem klaren Auge blind
dieses Positionspapier soll jetzt die
Lösung sein mit harter Hand gegen Glanz
fordert Berliner CDU-Chef Kai Wegner
zehn Punkte gegen das organisierte
Verbrechen
die Berliner CDU legt ihren Fokus auf
die Bekämpfung krimineller Großfamilien
in der Stadt sicher auch Kalkül die
Partei bringt sich für eine mögliche
Wahlwiederholung instellung und
positioniert sich klar der CDU-Politiker
fordert unter anderem permanente Razzien
und die stetige Beobachtung von
clan-mitgliedern brisant Kai Wegener
droht sogar kriminellen planeltern ihre
Kinder wegzunehmen Unterstützung kriegt
er aus Nordrhein-Westfalen Herbert Reul
NRW Innenminister und Deutschlands wohl
prominentester Politiker im Kampf gegen
die clankriminalität auch dort kommt es
immer wieder zu brutalen Straftaten
so wie hier in Duisburg im Mai diesen
Jahres kriminelle Großfamilie gegen
Rocker bewaffnete gewaltbereite Männer
ein Streit ausgetragen auf offener
Straße
nach dieser brutalen Auseinandersetzung
äußert sich Herbert Roll so ich glaube
wir greifen hart durch wir haben fünf
jedes fünfte Verfahren im organisierten
kriminalitätsbereich ist auf den klaren
Bereich zu zurückzuführen wir haben 10
Millionen Euro mittlerweile abgeschöpft
wir haben im zweistelligen Bereich Damen
und Herren in die Gefängnisse überführt
also ist eine Menge passiert aber es ist
auch eine Menge zu tun
zurück in Berlin allein im Jahr 2021
gingen hier nachweislich
849 Straftaten auf das Konto von
Kriminellen Großfamilien doch ein hartes
Durchgreifen gestaltet sich in der
rot-rot-grün-hauptstadt schwierig
schnell ist hier von Rassismus die Rede
für die Linke sind Razzien gegen
kriminelle Clans sogar stigmatisierend
die Forderung der Opposition längst
überfällig die Bekämpfung der Clan
Kriminalität notwendig
und Frank Schneider ist jetzt
zugeschaltet aus Essen Clan Experte
Frank warum tut sich die Hauptstadt so
schwer mit der clanbekämpfung beim
klappt das ja einfach nicht
ja wir haben es gerade im Beitrag gehört
da geht es um Stigmatisierung angeblich
um Rassismus und die Polizei hat dann
Angst und insbesondere die Politik in
Berlin regiert ja nicht umsonst
Rot-Rot-Grün dann könne man ihn ja
Vorwürfe entgegenbringen man würde
bestimmte Menschen kontrollieren aber
diese bestimmten Menschen machen nun mal
diese Straftaten und ein bisschen das
Problem für Berlin und auch übrigens für
Bremen die ja auch so regiert werden und
ähnliche Probleme haben ist natürlich
das NRW zeigt wie es geht der NRW
Innenminister ist nun mal CDU ist jetzt
in einer Koalition mit den Grünen da war
es auch eine große Diskussion den
Koalitionsgesprächen wie führt man diese
klangbekämpfung weiter und rollt zeigt
natürlich dass diese Taktik der 1000
Nadelstiche mit denen man angefangen hat
und Razzien wegen marathon-ratien haben
am Ende was gebracht es gibt sogenannte
strukturverfahren das heißt wirklich
Verfahren gegen die organisierte
Kriminalität und man sieht eben auch es
werden große Summen beschlagen und es
werden Autos beschlagnahmen es werden
Immobilien beschlagnahmen man sieht eben
es wirkt und das ist natürlich was
Berlin und auch prämiert sind Zugzwang
bringt das hört sich so an wie wenn du
jetzt sagen würdest Berlin scheut sich
einfach davor was müs Berlin jetzt
konkret anders machen und ja eben genau
nach diesem Vorbild von NRW
ja ich könnte einfach mal sagen berlin
braucht eine andere Regierung ich glaube
das unter Rot-Rot-Grün so etwas nicht
möglich ist weil man einfach reflexartig
sagt das dürfen wir nicht das
stigmatisiert ich habe das hier eine
Koalitionsverhandlungen gesehen zwischen
CDU und Grünen da ging es auch wirklich
eine Woche lang nur um die Diskussion
darf der Begriff Clans überhaupt in den
Koalitionsvertrag das muss man sich mal
vorstellen alle kennen das Problem alle
wissen dass dort massive Straftaten
begangen werden dass wir kriminelle
Großfamilien haben in ganz großen Stil
in Berlin in Essen hier insbesondere und
in Bremen aber es darf dann nicht
benannt werden also das wollen
jedenfalls die Grünen nicht da hat sich
Herbert Roll ganz klar durchgesetzt das
war eine der Knackpunkte in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen und das zeigt
natürlich ein wenig es geht dann nur um
politischen Kompass und politische
Ideologie und nicht um die Realität und
die Realität die haben wir eben gesehen
sind tumultelegte sind Schießereien auf
offener Straße sind massive Kriminalität
und muss noch eins sagen hier in
Nordrhein-Westfalen insbesondere in
Essen hat sich das deutlich verändert
auch das Straßenbild früher war das so
da wurde in dritte Reihe gepackt da
wurden Polizisten angegangen das trauen
die sich die Clans heute nicht mehr weil
Essen zum Beispiel hat jeden Tag eine
Hundertschaft hier sobald es irgendwo
Ärger gibt kommt diese Hundertschaft und
dann ist eben Ruhe tja sehr viel
Nachholbedarf hier in der Hauptstadt
Dankeschön Frank Schneider für deine
Einschätzung
[Musik]